Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new marvel fantastic four teaser trailer
video for the stuff that they dropped earlier they
dropped a bunch of marvel phase four trailers and
there's a bunch of fantastic four stuff in there
no surprise because it's going to be a really big
deal in a couple years so we'll break it all down
there's a bunch of big marvel stuff starting with
Wandavision episodes in a couple weeks i will be
doing videos for all those episodes so be sure
to subscribe to get all those and there's supposed
to be some special marvel phase 4 trailer event on
new year's eve in a couple days december 31st so
whatever footage that they release of course i'll
do videos for that too but most of you probably
saw kevin feige and marvel recently released this
teaser trailer for the new marvel fantastic four
reboot movie and finally i'm happy to announce a
film about one of the truly iconic marvel families
in fact marvel's first family fantastic four
we're working on a feature now and it will
be directed by the director of our recent
spider-man films john watts we've got a lot in
store at marvel studios and disney plus is key
to the interconnection and expansion of the mcu
it will be home for both our future films and
our series for years and years to come one of
the things i think people missed when he was
announcing that fantastic four movie is that he
said that disney plus would obviously be key to
setting all that stuff up that includes the new
version of the fantastic four so that'll all play
out during some of these early marvel phase four
series like i'll talk about during this video but
he also announces that john watts director of the
spider-man movies is going to be doing the movie
currently finishing spider-man 3 with tom holland
right now and if the news is to be believed andrew
garfield toby mugar in every person who's ever
been in a spider-man movie ever it literally seems
like everybody who's ever even whispered the words
spider-man is getting a cameo in that movie but
after they release spider-man 3 in december 2021
that's when john watts will start working on the
new marvel fantastic four movie which means we'll
probably be watching it by spring 2023 but as a
lot of you have seen there have already been a lot
of big marvel phase 4 easter eggs and teasers for
the fantastic four we just saw a bunch of new ones
in the new marvel phase 4 trailers they released a
couple weeks ago marvel's kind of doing the same
thing that they did with the infinity saga movies
setting up the infinity stones and thanos in
the background years and years before you ever
actually saw them in a legit movie like we got a
little teaser for thanos at the end of the first
avengers movie but he didn't actually show up as
a real character in a movie till guardians of the
galaxy the biggest fantastic four easter eggs so
far start with spider-man far from home so no big
surprise that the director of the new fantastic
four movie would have baked in some references
to one of his upcoming projects knowing that he'd
be doing the reboot movie once they finished the
mcu spider-man trilogy and just to be clear just
because john watts is moving on from spider-man
after spider-man 3 that doesn't mean it's
the end of tom holland spider-man and the mcu
so even if they don't do legit spider-man 4 in the
mcu tom holland will still show up in avengers 5
show up in other people's movies but that he
also might come back for a cameo in the new
fantastic four movie because he'd been working
with john watts for so many years now everyone
cue the hype train for the bombastic bagman in
the mcu now but the first three big fantastic
four easter eggs in spider-man far from home all
happen in rapid succession right at the end of
the movie when spider-man swings down to the newly
redesigned avengers tower ever since they released
that movie 84 years ago people have been wondering
what they're going to do with the avengers tower
now that somebody else bought it from iron man
would it be norman osborne and oscorp who bought
it because this is all happening in a spider-man
movie would it be black panther because he's one
of the only other people in the mcu that has that
kind of money to throw around or would it be reed
richards and the future foundation i think we can
probably say long term regardless of who owns it
right now for the next couple of years eventually
it will probably become the new baxter building
because kevin feige is a huge fantastic four fan
and he said that they're doing everything that
they can at marvel to ensure that the new movies
with the fantastic four will bring them up to the
level that they deserve as marvel's first family
and one of the ways you do that is you give them
this iconic landmark that used to represent the
avengers one of the biggest teams in the mcu so
the fantastic four now seems like the new biggest
team in the mcu before avengers 5 comes along the
sort of continuing this theme of setting up the
fantastic four the next big easter egg is the
construction sign so when he swings down you
see the one two three in question mark instead
of the four with the different colors the text
reads we can't wait to show you what comes next
obviously that's a reference to a bunch
of different things in marvel phase four
is a reference to marvel phase four itself like
we can't wait to show you all the new movies in
disney plus avengers spin-off series that we're
doing right now but as you probably spotted the
four numbers in the colors of the numbers also
correspond to the power sets of the fantastic
four so the one is red represents human torch
the two yellow represents the thing three blue
mr fantastic and the reason why you don't see the
four as a question mark is because it's meant to
represent the invisible woman it's invisible so
you can't see the four then the last little easter
egg here is when he swings down and they stand on
the street corner here at the intersection of east
41st and library way that's actually near yancey
street in the comics where the comic book version
of the baxter building resides then the next big
fantastic four easter eggs and teasers that we see
are in the marvel phase four trailers that they
also release at this big disney event mostly for
king the conqueror one of the mcu's upcoming
bigger time travel villains he's big enough
to be a thanos level threat but because they're
introducing him so soon i don't think he's going
to be the next thanos and in the role of kang the
conqueror we have a great actor jonathan magers
mcu king the conqueror is being played by jonathan
majors who you may remember from lovecraft county
he's an amazing actor so i'm really excited to see
what they do with this version of the character
he's going to be the main villain of ant-man 3
quantum mania he's a big young avengers villain
too so because they totally recast cassie lang
with catherine newton a bigger actress a lot of
people myself included think that it's because
they're slowly putting together a young avengers
team across all the new marvel phase 4 younger
characters in the disney plus series but the big
connection between kang and the fantastic four is
that kang is a time traveler from the very very
distant future and his real name before he started
calling himself king was nathaniel richards a
distant descendant of reed richards mr fantastic
we actually got the news that he was going to be
kang before they announced their new fantastic
four movie officially so we just felt like this
was all leading towards fantastic four eventually
anyway you mess with time it tends to mess back
you'll see famous almost last words from iron
man during avengers end game so you can kind of
see how they're sort of leading into kang being
another big villain coming up in more fantastic
four easter eggs the avengers start messing with
the quantum realm quantum energy time travel
alternate realities kang is the other side of that
that's why they're using him as the main villain
for ant-man 3. but the next big fantastic for
easter egg is that ant-man 3 isn't going to be the
first time that we hear about kang the conqueror
we're actually supposed to get our first taste
of that during the loki series in may when they
start releasing those episodes loki from avengers
end game steals the tesseract the space stone
and winds up getting caught by the time variants
authority they're kind of like the time masters
of the mcu the time cops the time lords make all
the references you want he's forced to go hunt
down and stop alternate versions of himself other
loki's from other timelines alternate realities
from wreaking havoc on time itself the one common
denominator across all the trailers that you see
is that in these different scenes it seems like
the earth becomes a wasteland completely destroyed
so the idea is that these other loki's are messing
with time in alternate realities and whatever
they do leads to the utter destruction of the
earth because of course it would we're talking
about loki here putting him in charge is literally
the worst thing you could possibly do so you wind
up with this funny situation where loki is both
the hero and the villain of his series but the
time variance authority monitors all time travel
all timelines in existence in the multiverse
so they clock time travel villains like kang
the conquer. kang wears different faces across
different timelines you see three very kang like
faces in the judge's chamber here up in the top
carved into the wood so we'll just get more early
kang the conker in the loki series helping set him
up so that everyone knows who he is when he shows
up in ant-man 3 further down the road and that'll
be more of a lead-in for fantastic four like
i said infinity saga teasing the infinity stones
eventually thanos and then giving us full infinity
gauntlet i don't know if he's actually supposed
to appear on screen during the loki series or if
they'll just reference him but the episodes will
be here in may so we won't have to wait very long
to find out what's going on with that series as
for fantastic four casting news kevin feige said
a while ago that they hadn't started casting yet
they probably kind of have an idea of who they're
looking at right now as for john krasinski and
emily blunt because there's been so much fan art
of them as the fantastic four for the past couple
of years there are rumors that they'll have marvel
cameos but the rumors are actually for doctor
strange too multiverse of madness in that they'd
be playing alternate versions of captain america
in black widow because once upon a time way back
during marvel phase one they were both almost
cast as those characters before they got married
to each other john krasinski wound up losing
out on the role to chris evans and emily blunt
actually turned down the black widow role in
iron man 2 and then that's when marvel went
to scarlett johansson having a big audience for
you must be a cool thing good for you i'm excited
good for you you made it chris we'll see how it
calls you don't fingers crossed everyone let me
know in the comments who do you want to play
the new version of the fantastic four all the
marvel Wandavision episodes are going to start
in a couple weeks of course i'll be doing videos
for that so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss any of those
there's also going to be two prequel episodes next
week for a series called marvel legends for them
i don't know exactly what that's going to be but
of course i'll do videos for it so there'll be two
episodes of that then the week after that is when
Wandavision episode 1 starts everyone click here
for my full loki trailer video in easter eggs and
click here for my new mandalorian season 3 luke
skywalker video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!